okay
well let me make a statement now i'm
piers morgan i am a man i identify as a
male i would hope that was reasonably
clear from my appearance but a great
number of businesses think we should be
displaying our pronouns in email
signatures or even name badges to avoid
the possibility of someone looking at me
for example and thinking i'm not sure
what he is if he doesn't have a little
name bag which i'm putting on myself
here now and i'll explain why in a
moment
let me just make sure i don't hit myself
with this pin um here we go there we go
so
halifax one of the biggest british banks
is asking staff to wear pronoun badges
they tweeted pronouns mata hashtag it's
a people thing
so far so virtue signaling and a welcome
step of course for inclusivity or was it
just bonkers well in just a moment i'll
be speaking to comedian james barr who
uses the pronouns he him his presumably
because he's a bloke and howard from
halifax who's wearing also pronouns he
him is but i don't think you really
think you want it do you have now howard
you might recognize because he was mr
halifax he used to be literally the guy
doing the ads for the bank take a look
maybe i'm a banker who's completely
obsessed
got a little something that's bound to
impress
this current account pays a higher
amount of extraordinary interest
okay well i'm with howard how great to
see you and comedian james barr is with
me as i mentioned james let me start
with you
here's the problem i have what halifax
did if you want to do this
badge thing i've been to conferences
where people wear badges if you want to
do it fine the problem i have what
halifax did is whoever runs their
twitter account not only tweeted a load
of virtue signaling nonsense around it
but also started telling anyone who was
objecting well then you can take your
custom elsewhere which i thought was a
startling piece of absurd over-the-top
virtue signaling for the twitter account
of a british bank to stick to handling
our money what's the matter with you all
your view well let me first of all just
say the whole country was really hoping
that you would get that whole pin thing
wrong just now but i'm glad that you are
okay it took me a while actually and i
didn't actually kill myself i'll tell
you why
at the moment it's hot hottest right
okay
and hot hotter hottest
or do you feel happy now that you are
identifying correctly i think if we're
going to go in down the road of any
pronouns you like i would like you now
in this interview to keep calling me hot
hotter or hottest do you think that's
reasonable i disagree but i'm very happy
to call you by those because i respect
your pronouns as halifax do with their
cousins you don't actually think i am
hot so why would you well i mean some
might but i i don't but that's how you
want to identify so that's how i now see
you peers but that's that's why i think
the whole thing is ridiculous and
getting more ridiculous and it's not
about you can't do it if you want to do
it fine but when i see a bank's twitter
account threatening customers and
telling them to leave if they don't like
it i'm like i think the customers were
threatening the bank and suggesting that
they thought it was awful and so they
replied with a clapback which is right
saying that if you disagree you can
close your account i think that's
brilliant that's exactly what we need
from our allies and people in this
community
virtue signaling imbeciles why do you
who's clearly a man i presume why do you
need to think about it
why do you need to have a badge saying
he him
because it shows people that i am
inclusive and i'm welcoming other people
are safe it's not you're just well
people that don't identify as he him or
she her or anyone to be honest they just
look you say go work go broke i say if
it ain't woke fix it like we need to be
telling people that they are safe in our
company don't need to be telling me that
they are he him
they know that they're men
i mean this argument is so boring i'm so
bored of having this conversation
companies doing it then
no companies need to do it the company
should do it let me bring in how it is
but james is entitled his opinion and
this show is uncensored you're
absolutely gonna have all sorts of
opinions and there'll be lots of people
that agree with him you used to be the
front man for the halifax when you saw
what they did here what did you think
well i gotta be honest i was a little
bit saddened by it to be honest with
your peers because
when when i first heard of this message
coming out where they were saying that
um you know they were changing certain
parts of of the organization and then if
you weren't happy with it you know you
could close your account i felt quite
sad about that because halifax has
always put its customers first and
rightly so
um and anything that detracts from that
i think is just wrong um you know we
prided ourselves in customer service
we positioned ourselves as the um you
know the country's um people's bank uh
and rightly so because we had great
accounts and we you know we considered
ourselves as a family and we wanted to
bring our customers in as a family so i
thought this uh thing was really bizarre
and i think it's just totally
unnecessary and we're seeing so many
companies now
getting into this virtue signaling about
these kind of issues and sort of
bullying people into going along with it
you know sort of freedom of speech and
you're on your right not to do this kind
of thing you're immediately condemned as
some kind of bigot if you don't wear
your pronoun badge or you don't do this
or you don't do that i really resent
that well i
i don't think that's right i think
because when you start individualizing
people that's when you have a problem i
just think that people need to take a
common sense look at this
um obviously from halifax's point if
they want to make changes that's fine
but i think that they've sort of you
know they sort of just missed a boat a
little bit on this one because their
focus should be on their customers we
all know that the customers of of of you
of your organization are your lifeblood
um so
you know to me i just find it really
really bizarre that they're being forced
i think that i i read something where
they said that there was a a choice i
would have to say that if i was still
working for halifax i wouldn't have a
badger pronouns i would have my name on
it but i don't think i would choose um
to have you know to specify a pronoun
that would just be simply my choice
right um
because you know and the funny thing
about it is a lot of people really don't
really take notice of main badge
something when you go to the branches
our customers just want to make sure
that we're looking after their banks
that's all i care about that's and let
me bring james back in at the end i mean
is there a thing that howard just said
he was the face of halifax anything he
said made you pause for thought uh no
because to be honest and without being
rude um howard hasn't been the face of
halifax for over ten years and is quite
frankly irrelevant in this conversation
as well as that i mean gay marriage
wasn't even legal when
howard was working
no i don't think it really matters at
all what does gay marriage have to do
with it
i'm just saying that the world is in a
very different place and this is all
about the customers but what does gay
marriage yeah sorry i mean i supported
gay marriage what the hell's that got to
do with wearing bags
your world is and it's a very small
world actually and the vast majority of
people in this country do not agree with
you it might be a startling shock to
your system but not everybody would like
to tell you this why is this so
offensive to you how is this affecting
you i find it offensive when a british
bank starts telling people on twitter
you can just
sod off if you don't want to wear the
pronoun badges
will follow suit and actually people
have to start putting their money under
their mattresses again because well
actually people will pick what people
will do they'll switch to other banks
because when companies go like this they
normally go broke very quickly you know
that i know so you think you speak
you don't speak for the majority i would
say you speak for less than 20 percent
of the country that you talk well
like
we're doing an amazing amazing thing by
thinking about that one percent of the
country that don't feel safe to walk out
of their front door and they're telling
that because no one's gonna feel safer
wearing a badge saying him he trust me
nobody nobody in the world if i would
feel less so as i said earlier when i
walk around with my back saying hot
hotter hottest i'm going to feel
seriously under threat of all these
things
male and female
because i'm so hot
for trans people and non-binary people
that aren't in the conversation isn't
this just wonderful actually i don't
think there's any conversation that
takes place at all these days without
trans people being mentioned so they're
in every conversation you know what
that's a very good point and they just
want a boring life pierce they see most
trans people i know do and they actually
are have far more common sense and they
think this kind of thing is ridiculous
most trans people i know it's not every
single trans person and it's the
activist elements who are destroying
lies for trans people by making these
stupid virtue signaling things all the
time all trans people
that's causing that trauma it's
interviews and conversations and debates
just like this trans people's lives are
not up for debate as i said they want a
boring life like you and me and possibly
unemployed my life isn't remotely boring
james and actually yours isn't you're a
funny guy you're a good comedian so i'll
give you that but it's a good debate
thanks for coming on i appreciate it
we're uncensored we like all of you
howard great to see you thank you and
you were the face of halifax and for me
you always will be thank you so much